seit dem filmklassiker back to the
future 2 aus dem jahre 1989 sind alle
verrückt nach dem hammer wort im film
heißt martin klein das jahr 2015 und
fährt dort unter anderem auf einem hof
an bord je näher wir dem 21 oktober
kommen das ist der tag an dem martin im
jahr 2015 an kommt desto mehr rabatt
scheint auf den markt zu kommen
aber ist das alles mehr fiction als 1
oder könnte ist ein echtes habe bord
wirklich geben die antwort gibt es jetzt
bei j
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
watts uns das cover bord ist seit über
25 jahren der traum von so ziemlich
jedem jungen und sogar der ursprung
vieler skater karrieren und genau diese
sehnsucht machten sich die jungs von
funnyordie 2014 zu nutze in einem
gefakten werbeclip wird das hubert cover
wort vorgestellt dabei sind unter
anderem einer der schauspieler von back
to the future und skate legende tony
hawk himself
das video wurde allerdings schnell als
fake enttarnt in wahrheit wurden die
schauspieler auf einen kran durch die
luft gezogen
viele back to the future fans blieben
enttäuscht zurück doch das feedback auf
das video damals hat gezeigt sehr viele
menschen sind an einem hammer bord
wirklich interessiert potenzial für eine
menge kunden
doch dieser mann konnte nicht zu lange
warten und hat sich kurzerhand sein
eigenes cover wort gebaut
es basiert zwar nicht auf magneten und
steht geräuschlos über den boden
aber es funktioniert mit hilfe von acht
propellern stellte der kanadier den
weltrekord im hammerwurf weitflug auf
ich wusste gar nicht dass es das gibt
275 meter weit flog der mann über wasser
und steuerte seinen hafer bord dabei mit
den eigenen füßen
laut eigenen angaben ist das das
weltweit erste echte und funktionierende
haver bord doch wirklich praktisch ist
das ding natürlich nicht neben der hohen
lautstärke und dem sperrigen format kann
es im moment auch noch nicht besonders
weit fliegen
und ich glaube es geht tricks sind damit
auch noch nicht so wirklich möglich
näher an diese vision kommt damit schon
handy
die firma hat auf kickstarter über eine
halbe million us dollar für die
entwicklung eines echten hammer boards
bekommen
ein prototyp existiert bereits und auch
dieser wurde von tony hawk getestet wie
ihr seht steht das ding leider nur über
einen boden aus kupfer ist auch relativ
sperrig lässt sich noch nicht wirklich
mit den füßen kontrollieren und was sie
leider nicht hören können
es ist verdammt laut der magnet
mechanismus der das wort schweben lässt
macht nämlich eine menge kraft wenn ihr
also ein kupfer wurden zu hause habt
dann könnt ihr das dingen ein paar
jahren für läppische 10.000 dollar
kaufen
nichts was sich normalsterbliche
wirklich aus spaß leisten können
aber das wort ist für händler sowieso
nur ein nebenprojekt die technologie
soll in zukunft ganze gebäude aus der
gefahrenzone von naturgewalten schweben
lassen
das sind große pläne die man leben
retten könnten
aber das hobart das inspektor future
versprochen hat ist das immer noch nicht
zur rettung alt lexus viele von euch
haben sie vielleicht mitbekommen vor
wenigen wochen hat lexus ein eigenes
cover bord angeteasert nachdem gefakten
videoclip von funnyordie haben natürlich
die allermeisten von euch sofort den
bullshit knopf gedrückt und behauptet
dass das alles nur eine große
werbekampagne ist und na ja das ist es
auch
slide wie lexus is nennt ist teil
mehrerer projekte wie wahrscheinlich das
design eines neuen autos anti sein
sollen und nein auch das schwebt
natürlich nicht aber auch wenn lexus
unsere hoffnungen und nerd räume hier
eiskalt ausnutzt um werbung zu machen
heißt das nicht dass das cover bord von
lexus nicht echt sein kann
auf ihrer website schreiben sie dass das
cover board mit hilfe von supraleitern
und magneten die quanten levitation
erreicht ein supraleiter das material
hat keinen elektrischen widerstand und
muss dafür sehr stark abgekühlt werden
lexus behauptet dass sie die benötigten
niedrigen temperaturen mit hilfe von
flüssigem stickstoff erreichen können
das würde auch den effektvollen nebel
erklären an und für sich funktioniert
diese technik sehr gut wie man ihnen
diesen genialen video sehen kann
lexus ansatz ist zwar leiser als die
technik die hände verwendet dafür muss
das material aber immer wieder gekühlt
werden vermutlich verschwindet der
supraleiter effekt schon nach wenigen
minuten danach muss wieder nach gekühlt
werden aber auf einen magnetischen boden
kann auch lexus an bord nicht verzichten
zur arbeit oder zur schule schweben kann
man auch hier mit total vergessen
solange eure stadt nicht jeden einzelnen
bürgersteig in der ganzen stadt umbauen
lässt im teaser von lexus ist allerdings
beton zu sehen irre führen
aber wie so oft kommt das internet zu
hilfe anscheinend hat jemand entdeckt
dass lexus in spanien an einem echten
skaterpark arbeitet und noch viel
wichtiger
unter der unfertigen oberfläche kann man
klar und deutlich erkennen dass an einem
metall boden gearbeitet wird lexus
wollte natürlich nicht dass jemand den
skaterpark außerhalb von barcelona sid
wo vorher fertig ist und es ist auch
noch nicht klar auf dieser parcours
gebaut wird um coole videos zu drehen
oder ob auch normale menschen zugang
bekommen werden so oder so ist das alles
verdammt spannend und aufregend und ich
würde wetten dass wir alle
allerspätestens am 21 10 oktober 2015
mehr über das hammer bord von lexus
erfahren werden
was meint ihr ist lexus hat echt oder
ist das alles nur ein genialer
marketingtrick schreibt sie auf jeden
fall unten in die kommentare schon sehr
gespannt was ihr dazu zu sagen habt wenn
ihr mehr von lausanne sehen wollt findet
ihr rechts die beiden letzten videos der
schnellste zug der welt der heimflug von
tesla und virtual reality
das ganze findet ihr unten viel spaß und
bis zum nächsten mal